COME TO ORDER IN RESPONSE TO
THE COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING MPAS COVERING
GUIDELINES. IT COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE BORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN CAPITAL ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE BUT NONE OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. AND ROUTE FORTY TWO
OR THREE WITH ME OR SOON TO BE
SENATORS CORTESE DOLLY GLAZER
MCGUIRE- CHILDHOOD BUT BOTH
ENHANCE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
WILL BE USING A TOP US. I TELL
CONFERENCE AROSE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE A PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE THREE AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN ZERO FIVE SIX
NINE ZERO NINE FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS.
PLEASE REFER TO THE. SENATE
INDOOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO POP COMMENT YOU
WILL BE. BY MADRE TO DIE ONE
ZERO FOR SOME IN OPPOSITION.
THIS IS ONLY ONE TIME AND
PLEASE WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU'LL BE A MUTED AND YOU'RE
NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU ARE ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON. PARTY GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE LEGISLATIVE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE ROAD
MEETING SERVICE I HAVE THE
CONNECTIONS NEEDED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS. IT'S
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LIKE TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS
COURT JUSTIN TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES MAY BE HEARD. WE HAVE
TWO BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA. WE
ARE HEARING SB THREE THIRTY BY
SENATOR. PER SERVICE PURSUANT
TO RULE TWENTY NINE POINT ONE
ZERO. SB THREE THIRTY WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY AMENDED AFTER IT
LEFT THE SENATE THE SENATE IS
HEARING SB THREE THIRTY IN ITS
CURRENT FORM FOR THE FIRST TIME
TODAY. ONE BILL IS ON CONSENT
ITEM NUMBER TWO S. R. 55% OF
PORTANTINO. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILL'S
LOUDEST TEMPERATURE QUORUM.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR LEYVA HERE LIVING HERE-
CHAU BOVE. THE TROUBLE CARE
COURTESY YOUR ATTENTION HERE
GALLEY. GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN AM
HERE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM
CONSULTANT. NOW THAT THEY CAN
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. THANK YOU CENTER PANNED
THE CONSENT CALENDAR HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR PAN CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CONSENT
SENATOR LEYVA BY THE WAY-
TROUBLE BUG THE BOGUE AYE
CORTESE. COURTESY I DALY GLAZER
MCGUIRE PAN AM HI. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL BE THE BILL ON
OR THE CONSENT CALENDAR ON CALL.
CENTER DRAWS A WELCOME AND YOU
MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL SB THREE
THIRTY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FONG AND GOOD. OF SB THREE
THIRTY EIGHT WAS LAST HEARD
SINCE S. B. C. B. THIRTY WAS
LAST HEARD THE BILL WAS
NARROWED TO BECOME A TEN YEAR
PILOT PROGRAM FOR THE LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. HEAD OF A STATE WIDE
PROGRAM THE TEN YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM WILL ENABLE- ELLIE CCD
TO REPURPOSE UNDER UTILIZED
REAL PROPERTY OR EXISTING
FACILITIES INTO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND AUTHORIZES- ALI
CCD TO ENTER INTO LEASES OR
AGREEMENTS WITH PRIVATE
ENTITIES ARE NONPROFITS FOR
JOINT OCCUPANCY A REAL PROPERTY
AND BUILDINGS FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THIS BILL EXTENDS HOW
LONG L. A. CCD MAY ENTER INTO.
THE AGREEMENT- FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FROM FIVE YEARS TO
SIXTY SIX YEARS AND ALSO
ALLOWS- ALI CCD TO LEASE REAL
PROPERTY FOR LESS THAN FAIR
RENTAL VALUE THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL ARE PERMISSIVE THIS
BILL HAS NO LISTED OPPOSITION-
AND IF THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS
MISTER ALEX ELENI'S ON BEHALF
OF L. A. C. C. D. IS AVAILABLE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO
TO LEAD SUPPORT WAS THE WITNESS
ARE MR ALANIZ IS ONLY HERE FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS NO HATE I
MEAN I JUST FIVE O'CLOCK YEAH
VERY GOOD NO OF YOU MAY I.
WHATEVER YOUR YOUR PLEASURE IS
MADAM CHAIR PERFECT THANK YOU
SO YOU DO HAVE LEAD SUPPORT
EIGHT IN EACH PERSON HAS TWO
MINUTES. SO MISTER ALEX. ALANIZ
PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHERYL LEYVA AND OF THE-
ARAMBULA. ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. I WANT TO EXPRESS
VALLEY CCD STRONG SUPPORT FOR
SB THREE THIRTY. I KNOW YOU'RE
VERY BUSY TODAY SO I'LL KEEP MY
REMARKS SHORT- SUPPORTED PILOT
PROJECT IS ALLEY CCD ESSENTIAL
TOOLS TO ADDRESS A HOUSING
CRISIS FACING BOTH THE STUDENT.
AND EMPLOYEE THE VALLEY CCD.
THE BILL ESTABLISHES A PILOT
PROGRAM FOR ALLIE CCP TO ENTER
INTO LEASES OR AGREEMENTS WITH
PRIVATE ENTITIES FOR JOINT
OCCUPANCY OF REAL PROPERTY.
BUILDINGS FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR STUDENTS OR
EMPLOYEES. OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT. ONE OF THE
PILOTS PROGRAM LACC BE MORE BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THE- AND RETAIN
ALL. PROTECTIONS CURRENTLY OFF
BY STATE. BUT THE PARTNERSHIP
IS TO PROVIDE OF HOUSING MAKES
AN EXCEPTION FOR REQUIRING THE
HIGHEST MONITORED OF RETURN. AS
YOU ARE AWARE RENTS VERY IN
EVERY IN A LOCKED REGION.
EXPONENTIALLY HEARD STUDENTS ON
THIS BILL WILL HELP ALLEVIATE
EXISTING STUDENT HOUSING
BURDENS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT YOU VOTE I HONESTLY THREE
THIRTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO ANY SUPPORT
CARE ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
SEEING NONE WILL MOVE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NONE WE
WILL NOW GO TO OUR PHONE LINES
MODERATOR CAN YOU QUEUE UP
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE THIRTY.
FOUR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE THIRTY PLEASE PRESS ON
AND THEN ZERO. A COMMAND AGAIN
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE
NO COMMENT AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR WE WILL MOVE
TO OPPOSITION NOW I SHOW NO
LEAD OPPOSITION SO WE WILL GO
HERE TO FORTY TWO OR THREE.
SIGNAL OPPOSITION WILL GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEING NO
OPPOSITION MISTER MODERATOR CAN
YOU QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB THREE THIRTY. FOUR COMMENTS
IN OPPOSITION TO BE THREE
THIRTY PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE
END ZERO. BACK COMMAND AGAIN
ONE THEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE TO HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR PAN CENTER DRAWS A
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH VERY GOOD THANK YOU THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
PAN MAN CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
SB THREE THIRTY THE MOTION IS
THAT THE AMENDMENTS TO BE
CONCURRED IN SENATOR LEYVA. HI
THEY'VE AYE OCHO ABOVE I THE
TROUBLED HI COURTESY I CORTES
THE AYE DALY. GLAZER MCGUIRE
PAN. AM I. THINK YOU CENTER
DRAWS A WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK YOU TO
OUR MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE RIGHT
ON TIME AND- WE'RE ALL GOOD TO
GO WE. WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
FOR OTHER MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT SO
ARE IN THE BLAZERS NOT HERE. I
DON'T KNOW. WHERE YEAH. OKAY.
START WITH CONSUMPTION CENTER.
CONSULTANT WE'RE GOING TO LIFT
THE CALL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR PLEASE CONSENT CHAIR
VOTING ON A VICE TO ROUTINE I
DALY GLAZER MCGUIRE THE FOUR
VOTES THAT BILLS OUT FOR
NOTHING FOUR ZERO NOW PLEASE IF
YOU'LL PLEASE LEAVE THE CALLS
ON SB THREE THIRTY. FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB THREE THIRTY THE
MOTION IS THAT THE AMENDMENTS
BE CONCURRED IN VOTING I
ADVISED HER VOTING ONLINE DAILY
GLAZER MCGUIRE THAT BILLS OUT
FOUR ZERO THANK YOU TO ALL OF
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU'RE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY. AND
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU FOR TO
RUN FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION IS
ADJOURNED.